were so full podcast with Felipe Esparza
and me that's it
Rodrigo's not here he's doing Mexico I
found out he took his shine with him
he's older with his girlfriend in Mexico
I don't know when he's coming back now
she's over there not long as date hey
man who are you doing this weekend who
the Mexico her I'll go with you honey
bunny and so I was so weirdly not to
have ever see well Ginga with a
girlfriend because I thought this guy
was never gonna have a chick Torrio's
man ok to jerk off to his wrist all off
no for real I really thought there was
no hope for this guy like like he was
going on Backpage Craigslist he harmony
trying to hook up with homie sisters you
know anybody that had a sister a man who
grew your sister but he never asked to
get hooked up he was too picky I talking
about fat foods that are not attractive
they're very picky
I had a friend named Tony who's very
picky like one time mom we were checking
out Cameron Diaz and I thought you were
pretty you know I like her I like her
little dimples on her cheeks and then I
asked her well you you don't think she's
attractive your man she's like a [ __ ]
Mouse really [ __ ] I'll [ __ ] your
mouse who are you that's what I deal
with when single men are always things
are single because they're just too
picky like she's - she look like a mouse
like like he had a chance with Cameron
Diaz had a chance had no chance then
Rodrigo didn't like girls with big
thumbs I don't know why but yeah man we
were like you guys no no get on Rodrigo
that much but yeah man I'll remember
that for having a girlfriend ever
oh yeah he did have one girlfriend when
I was living in Echo
work he was dating this girl who just
came out of prison so Wow
there's plenty men like she would have
to pull over and buy her a pack of
cigarettes that she smokes a lot
pullover babe let's get a pack of
cigarettes buy me a pack of cigarettes I
don't think I ever bought a woman a pack
of cigarettes in my life and if she were
to ask any woman would ask me Felipe who
you bought a pack of cigarettes I would
have said man I don't think I know you
that well I'm Greek
our relationship is got strong but I
could just go there and buy a pack of
cigarettes for you BH what's wrong with
you get your pocket cigarette and I
never gave me some [ __ ] cigarettes no
way man but getting back to the subject
well drinker is in Mexico with his his
shine his shine what the hell do they
talk about could I pour it not that
funny I mean that Iran I seen him say
some horrible stuff to women like
Marshall Arguello or or people or women
that are around us man she will be very
patient man
big-ass body on top of somebody other
people imagine my fat ass hooked up with
somebody they imagine me on top of them
what now what's up fool last week I was
in town I Vietnam I've been home now for
about a week and a half
cabin fever I'm ready to [ __ ] take
off and go back to work [ __ ] boring
at home man I don't know what to do I'm
getting fatter by the [ __ ] minute
every time I come home I gained 15
pounds I leave I lose eight I should be
out of town more man I know just gonna
get bored you [ __ ] start eating like
I don't I don't have nothing to do for
eight hours or 12 or 13 I read a book I
start eating I watch TV I start eating
I eat before I eat like my wife is
cooking something I make a pre snack
because I'm the king of pre snacks she's
making something and I feel and I'm
thinking man that shit's gonna take 45
pocket minutes to make
so I better eat a 10 minute sandwich I
do that a lot I don't do it anymore but
I was about a lot like she's making
something take 45 minutes I see all
right I just won't eat anything that
she's making okay she's making beans
[ __ ]
can't make a bean burrito right now she
making enchiladas [ __ ] I can't make a
case of the air right now I might have
my enchiladas right now so how you how
you read it read remedy that you get a
big-ass bowl of [ __ ] cereal I love
cereal man I think I love more cereal
more after I moved out of my mom's house
so if I'm a mom's house you could only
cereal in a [ __ ] morning boring what
the [ __ ] wants to eat cereal or [ __ ]
morning I want a serie for [ __ ]
desert a man frosted flakes banana after
a burrito forget apologies good
I love frosted flakes I'm not even I'm
not even our sponsor
I just love frosted cereal except one
thing you cannot go cheap on its frosted
flakes
you cannot go cheap you got to get the
frosted flakes any other cereal doesn't
taste the same like I've had the Mexican
spotty flakes full of Tito's plecos no I
was called on to kirito's Spanish Cyril
don't even [ __ ] around they just tell
what it is
sook I eat those they made a play
downwards on sugar that's like calling
frosted flakes
Sugarland sugar lad you want some sugar
land
however when cereal you can come with
good [ __ ] prices man see I'm a Mormon
older man sometimes they need to be a CD
connected to the frosted place like all
a CD that actually played we got our
grandma over here talking about um
there's to be a 45 record but when I was
a kid although there was I'm a serial I
think it was done giggles max it came
with an album in the back I had a 45 and
I think of the haunted house music I
don't know what it was but there's no
more cereal there's no more good prizes
I remember getting a knife
that wasn't a knife or the ruler I bit
into an iPhone but it but they don't
give away good good presidents no more
on the project lakes or the other
stereos I guess cuz everybody has money
now you can buy a better toy but when I
was a kid it was tough to get good toys
so um you opened up your box of cereal
there might be a GI Joe in there
I doubt it there was no [ __ ] GI Joe I
- hi - hi just my stuff in Syria you
ever do that you want to hide stuff so
you hide stuff in cereal I was living
alone and I don't know why when I was
living with myself I don't know why I
was - my weed somewhere no one ever came
and the only one who couldn't find it
with me because I forget what the [ __ ] I
put it so one day I'm eating cereal and
half an ounce of weed comes out of the
cereal I'm like what Tony the Tiger dude
gave me a half an ounce
[ __ ] yeah they're great shut up people
shout out to put on my glasses here man
because you know I can't see [ __ ] I
gotta read now Jeff Shannon's Martinez
from your boyfriend
shanon's Martinez shoutout from your
boyfriend sneaker head 1879 for the
great I to review ours was the first
podcast he ever listened to and he's
been hooked ever since
thanks for listening keep reviewing and
commenting on itunes about the show
upcoming shows tonight may 18 to 20
first Tempe Arizona that's right last
night's show was crazy but today is
Friday and we're going to do it up may
25th to 28th Irvine improv June 1st
through the 4th Arlington Texas at the
Arlington improv July 1st at Ava
amphitheater with Paul Rodriguez
Tierra Malo and war tickets go on sale
tomorrow Saturday May 20 it's about time
I worried about this job July 13 to the
15 Corpus Christi Texas at Mesquite
Street comedy club
check out Filippis world.com / - a frost
rotate for the rest of the year also
shout out to UM there's the many um
podcast with um Latino comedians there's
some out there but not that many I'm not
the first and I'm not gonna be the last
but every once in a while you know I'm
on audio boom and I happened to listen
to some podcasts that I never heard of
or some that I've heard of or I never
listened to I listened to them for a
little while then I give up I listen to
uh dog steinhoff last podcast last week
let the whole thing just half of it got
bored I got bored but I will do
something else but yeah was very
interesting it's funny they had a guy
from vice also some other podcast I
don't know who the host is but I
listened to it for 10 minutes then I
gave up what when it turned into like
Rafa and Chicano Movement all that [ __ ]
it was called Chicano eat never heard of
that podcast
sound like to educated people talking
older you know what I ate yesterday I
had a pupusa
I need a Fantana I am so delicious
yes without a podcast a little tool
which she kind of eats also another
podcast I would listen to it was this
one is real far left total far left so
left it might go right The Young Turks
and its top political podcast so weird
some comments around it very interesting
you want to know about the far left go
to YT y T y so Young Turks and another
part get a little tour I stopped living
into it because I have a new phone and
most of my party got deleted is um
grammar girl with uh whatever the lady
name is I have to follow her own [ __ ]
snapchat to fell on me on so let me know
another name is yeah that's her name
so let me on no it's me John sub did put
it stuff like hood to let me on it's
pretty cool man
knows another popular you listen to
because I would turn up better my
Spanish it was called um cafe con
espanol and they would a weird manic I
didn't learn no [ __ ] Spanish on that
[ __ ] pot podcast I learn more English
since podcast first starts off the
Spanish cafe one the guy who teach to
Spanish edition from Switzerland he
Swiss he's Irish he's an Irish Meccano
he's a leprechaun oh and they start
talking about it and then I don't know
man and children to a pirate story in
Spanish and I couldn't keep up with it
so I stopped listening to it but man
when I thought my you know my Spanish is
Italian bad as my English or is worse
than my English but it's not great
Spanish a team all my Spanish is made up
words I made up but then start talking
es lo bueno es una con el Casa La Paz
care take a fearless
no rest a momento tenemos a-- we are
richard richard attack in a porter my
heart i ii man screw that out too boring
but i'm finished another broke this here
my first book I finished it and it was
fresh Stoller's book 20 the the book he
wrote the one he he was promoting here
the Kindle single I think go through a
hundred Kindle singles in a year if
they're all that fast it was a good book
and you want to know more about Fred
Stoller go read the book
Warren Thomas Seder David Spade and Rob
Schneider and Jan something but it's a
good book man it really breaks down
stand-up comedy in those times then only
where I'm gonna be in in 20 years
my gonna be doing a podcast am I gonna
be doing stand-up comedy I just hope to
get live leather food are dying so
people are afraid to go to a hospital
because they don't wanna find out what's
wrong with them I tell you what's wrong
with me man I waste bucket 289 pounds
with my clothes on
I mean with my clothes off I weigh I
can't believe some time that I weighed
289 pounds I guess I don't see myself
that much because I'm when I think about
somebody way 289 pounds I have to expect
someone to be so fat they can't [ __ ]
move and walk like a bro you wanna go
for a walk [ __ ] you brought away 200
[ __ ] 89 pounds I ain't going nowhere
but I get up every morning do it do
every morning I get up every morning and
I pretend I'm still sleeping cuz I don't
want this [ __ ] I don't wanna do nothin I
don't wanna go you know go grocery
shopping I don't want to I don't want to
go for a walk I don't want to get I
don't get my day started until after I
pretend I'm not sleeping
I get up in the morning and I do 30
push-ups 30 I can't do more than that
I mean I could do 40 but I want to do it
for that do 30 push-ups then I stopped
then I do another 30 push-ups so I do a
average of 50 pushups every morning and
then during the day if I'm if I'm bored
I just stop what I'm doing and I do
another 20 push-ups
so I average around seventy-five to a
hundred push-ups during the day never
doing that now for I would say since
last November since November or October
of last year I've been doing everyday
push-ups I haven't noticed that anything
about my body
I don't feel buffer I'm out of shape I'm
on a breadboard split time but and I do
these um sit-ups that I really like I
said I started that few days ago where
you want just lay there and lift your
legs up and then you touch your knees
but laying down I like doing exercises
that involve laying down let's crush it
out laying down crack it back benchpress
I'm down for all that but jogging man I
don't want to [ __ ] up my knees man I
can't mess up my knees I will reading I
watching the commercial about exercise
and health and fitness and one more
thing that they say is something that
nobody ever does before trying out this
physical exercises before going on on
and this diet please see a physician who
who has ever done that before and if you
have please write in a letter let us
know how it went who had ever once you
go see the doctor first and then recite
you on a diet no man you wait - you're
out of
breath then you go to a doctor then he
tell you listen you [ __ ] your fat [ __ ]
getting the [ __ ] diet you're gonna die
but that never the case you just like we
just want to do it all in one day like I
want you to exercise everything I could
do in one day because that's all I have
is one day that's that's the way I will
see my life like I always saw my life
like esterday not a year from now not
five years from now Tuesday and that's a
problem when I start focusing on Jason
today I seek today sucks so based on
today I think my whole life sucks and my
whole year sucks but no man it's just
one hour the whole day doesn't suck
it's just that one hour of the day when
you are feeling like [ __ ] that sucks but
you need to jump I love that feeling man
I don't know how you do it I can't give
you advice on how to how to knock your
life [ __ ] but you can't appreciate the
good victories in your life that's
something I can't do like celebrate what
I have now instead of what I don't have
or where my neighbor has or what the
other comedian has or what they have I
was gonna talk together about what I
have now because I have a lot I have a
beautiful wife have a podcast that
provides us to do our teens comedy
shoutout I do stand-up comedy I have an
agent I have money saved I paid all my
bills I don't owe nobody [ __ ] honestly
let me tell you either
I'm not rich but waking up every morning
knowing that I don't owe anybody
anything
it's like being rich that talk to that
should be a product because before like
I would say seven years ago in 2010 I
was nobody everybody always said I was
broke I had no money no man I had money
but I wasn't spending my money right
just say my rent was my rent was back
then was nineteen hundred bucks a month
and I had to pay nine hundred and ninety
dollars of it I still have money to do
drugs
no matter where I was what situation I
was in
there was always money for drugs and
rent of course but there was no money
for cars luxury vacations
I guess my when you're broke so you
think you're broke the only vacation you
have it to do a little bump or get
really high or stuff your face with a
bunch of hot pockets but yeah man I
would listen to the other podcast this
podcast I found interesting and it was
it's called um home how to think like a
millimeter even though you're not a
millionaire it's called um let me see
here I got it right here
it's called god damn it it's called this
podcast I was listening to it's called
here it is creating spaces anybody heard
of it creating spaces with hosts with
night I listen to his podcast for maybe
like 30 minutes then I gave up but they
had a guy there who was talking about
how together was a host she was talking
about um um whatsit play also like to be
a Salesman I get but fear not we're not
our salesmen here
we don't sell stuff but what we do
everyday what I do everyday or for
example every time you meet somebody
every time you say hello to somebody you
pretty much selling yourself to that
person you know they're seen the way you
shook their hand the way
you smiled you know you pretty much
studying yourself I was telling myself
short now and this guy was talking about
how and I related to him so much so he
said listen man I'm not the smartest guy
in the room I am NOT the most articulate
person in the room but I know what this
room needs and that's and I'm if I know
what they need I know how to provide for
them and that's how I feel man
in my comedy my stand-up comedy I'm not
the most articulate comedian you know
I'm not the smartest comedian but I know
what this audience wants I know what the
audience is thinking I know what the
people that come to my show are thinking
I know how they think I know how they
feel I know what they want and I give it
to them I give them a little silly ass
drug addict jokes tell them about my
life how I grew up so should I do
and then what life is man to myself if
you know what people want and you got it
you're gonna be successful whether if if
you doubt they're giving away hugs for
free Hey give it to somebody happy give
it up for a hug man oh [ __ ]
what's up for we got everybody here you
can sit down here two of you want even
gonna be shy you can still make the
handlers doing here oh yeah happy Wars
Oh foo yeah what's up fool what software
we got a zone here yep and stony dance
all right Tony Danza in effect in the
flesh man let me tell you man a couple
you a member of story doesn't mean but
that's good man Jill I'm a runaway boy
boy I stole your dancers okay he'll
remember ba ba ba ba if he is yes what
yeah that's right now that's my new name
is Tony danger
okay Pokiri nurse Tony Danza hahaha he's
live where Tony Danza watching him again
chika Dalek she could die away chic chic
a Dalek Yoda
since the moment I met you the first
time in the second time and now your
demon aashica Delhi High it's okay I
drink all [ __ ] up - how you go called
a dog cheeky because now I can be shaky
or something
this is the I take your ah - it was too
funny dog dancing my name what up take I
think he's a know your name but I knew
was shaky so just make it make your name
song cool wrong shaky now your name is
psychedelic right she's pathetic she
could die there but he was well ji ho
Chan I remember it but he knew didn't
know it but he wanted to make it sound
like he knew it but [ __ ] it up
Hey Shiki deli more songs who got the
official we don't smoke the same group
here
I just straight outta be real TV right
now no but we just left the temple what
is it beast is back in town and we're
like let go where you guys going
you guys never leave this [ __ ] early
and we just like our piece we found it -
you guys live without pulling one up
so whatever man what welcome to the war
so full podcast why no I'm just talking
about um how how a lot of times you know
you know um you don't have to be the
most articulate person in the room you
know or the smartest room in the forest
personal room or the most famous person
in the room but all I think doesn't
matter if you know what the people one
yes what the audience wants to listen to
what the [ __ ] they want if you give them
what they want they're gonna [ __ ]
love you know you meet that demand man
yeah man but see how hard is it knowing
what the [ __ ] they want it depressing
like us yeah like I know what my
audience was it was to pee really bro
audience is kind of the same they like
stupidity but they just like it with
weed yeah you know what I mean yes yeah
let me take the largest dab you can and
just act [ __ ] after
yeah like it's me you can like like
right Chester the waters which is like
I'm like I wonder if I like approach him
and try to get the intellectual
[ __ ] to try to like see if
they're on there I get some love but I
should look like 10 likes god forbid I'm
over here 10 grams at one time I say
goes viral like you can't be too smart
yeah like you you can't [ __ ] do that
not a dick to see those is that to man
like like when a person has a jeweler
Instagram video and he has like a
[ __ ] two feet dab yep and they're
like he spoken at [ __ ] by himself he's
getting all the likes from everybody
that can't even afford that big dab like
just it goes viral doc because this is
like people are like oh this guy must be
living lavish if you could afford that
[ __ ] but that's like lining up the Vig
israel--and like you're doing that [ __ ]
in front of everybody be like ya fool I
just spent that [ __ ] oh hell no that big
rail car sort of ways for doing a steady
castle that you to do the longer real
and not die that means that [ __ ] week
yeah for real like the homie in America
me when he makes him like snort you can
starting a new estate alive that was
crazy to Merkin me huh
yeah you know who we are we are and man
if you talk about that scene in bloody
and I'm working me man their story pure
heroin up yeah that's what I feel passed
out man they all died right all only
make everybody in hell in that room and
they all died yeah man didn't even take
the [ __ ] heroin the sad part now but
it's sad because some of them mad
well the first walking out of the words
because his nose broke on the way to hit
that table oh yeah so you have to snort
that show the bloody ass nose - I must
have been like all congested and [ __ ]
like the 405 in his nose I woulda said
give me shoots over to wait he should
have had that nasal spray dawg
you know I don't know what we're hearing
about I think it was Joey Diaz the other
day he was talking about the lifecycle
he had some dude where like he said all
I was he was doing it so much that this
will mix it with water Jersey I think it
was yeah yeah he wasted it yeah and he
made that little Donald Duck noise like
I'm like what the [ __ ] that's like some
innovator [ __ ] that's like somebody
there's like
we'll make a bong out of this table or
some [ __ ] yeah I'll hit that party let's
get to the nasal spray and make it what
put like a bunch of coconut bottom and
then fill the rest with water and just
shook it and it was like pure water coke
hit so let me do a bump some of it get
stuck right here in the cavity so you
got north of water with that little
spray you don't need no snow
dominicality right makes it smooth
that's like that you know and that's
like the the same shittiest owner would
appreciate something like that if you do
it and find a way to get high with weed
that's the kind of [ __ ] that our
audience [ __ ] goes crazy for like you
ever seen those videos of like
[ __ ] making a pipe out of a
banana or something I'm like there's no
point in that I am like it doesn't make
your high any better but the fact that
they're like yeah you made that [ __ ] out
of banana against I would ever be so
violent yeah all that that crazy white
boy that um he put that milk instead of
his nose oh yeah hit it like that was
that the big fool no son white boy
he wasn't that big you put a dog inside
his up inside his no they lit that [ __ ]
yeah there's there's one dude who's
known for doing this crazy [ __ ] with
dabs I'm forgetting his name but this
[ __ ] filled the rake with
sriracha and [ __ ] hit it dawg [ __ ]
crazy like like he's filled that [ __ ] up
with sriracha like not even like
straight ahead like we're not even water
like just straight like the syrup or
whatever the [ __ ] actual
concentration is hit the dab we're
boarding our hotel room in Houston and
where there's a bunch of teeth right
Rodrigo at night and we're rolling our
blood with keep on it and then let him
in rogelio leg he made a line with the
Keith and I said bro just [ __ ] know
that [ __ ] bro so happens nothing
happened bro he because it has to be
hard Ansel yeah he didn't do a line
where he's broke just slowly that [ __ ]
and he didn't get no energy a feeling in
the wireless yeah he didn't get sick
nothing but he was shining bro
shut the [ __ ] up Rodrigo did this [ __ ]
yeah he did a line of cheese he say
Yemen he says yeah man damn I said
nothing happened I've seen fools do that
[ __ ] on video and like that [ __ ] like it
goes like that [ __ ] burns the [ __ ] out
of there I cuz he was burning bro oh so
it wasn't Pleasant though with the
pleasant well I thought he's just like
but took it out it wasn't like when you
snore what sob you looking at that now
starburns like that but nothing happened
man it was like he died with a get high
man that was okay we were all been doing
it oh yeah you know what right now yep
this good is gonna come it's gonna come
a time and a point we're like that's
going to be the next step like I feel
like they're gonna try to make we
versions of these harder drugs like they
already have we'd lean you know for
people that like [ __ ] mixing that
syrup you know like that promethazine
they have we lean to shoot up yeah like
they're gonna give you like y'all shoot
this I guess I have your are it's gonna
be like a kid what is the injectable THC
[ __ ] I'll be cool man like one little
one little Tom a green star in one of
those syringes that I'm diabetic used
there are federal noodle needles so just
put it around just sprays it inside I
never seen that for that matters yeah
it's like a little microphone and you're
a guy who's had a he was afraid of
needles so it's like a microphone and
just takes it to an arm and then just
goes in there it's quick quick like no
needle just poke stainless we need that
for marijuana and coke I need that war
so food today's episode is sponsored by
Dollar Shave Club Dollar Shave Club
still going strong at our sponsor
where'd you go use what you go uses it
and loves it you heard him talk about it
it's all space and close shave that
keeps him shining do you know why Dollar
Shave Club is the smarter choice why why
mine it's a great shave at a great price
conveniently delivered right to your
door man
that's right now your neighbors can't do
another package or your house don't have
to go to a store and get more razors
because you know how hard that [ __ ] is
kids are locked up they're locked up
well [ __ ] man hey and with every day
on store yeah so can you unlock the
similac milk and the shavers there's a
button on the [ __ ] shaver thing that
you push they like lights this [ __ ] up
like as if you're just like you trying
to get a gun or some [ __ ] they have that
next to the Cologne those things are
locked up crazy time also comes with the
awesome dr. Carver's shave butter which
helps prevent ingrown hairs and fight
razor bumps but when an ingrown hair man
I don't grow as a man in world pubic
hair bro ingrown pubic hair yeah but
it'll being gonorrhea what
YouTube can make the smarter choice by
joining Dollar Shave Club as one of our
listeners for a limited time only new
members get their first month of the
executive razor with the tube of the dr.
Carver shape club for only $5 for only 5
bucks your first box will arrive and
you'll get an awesome heavy handle razor
or focus set of four cartridges and a
tube of the shea butter no hidden fees
no commitment cancel anytime you want to
get this deal join today at Dollar Shave
Club calm /foo - dollarshaveclub.com
slash food you shave she comes like once
a month once it takes time
you got that felt like a delayed
American Idol era it sucks I just
started shaving bro and I'm [ __ ] in
my forties roll in your forties you
could barely started going to bearings
well I had a great beard before I feel
[ __ ] shame a great beard you know I
don't really like it too much
I usually just go to the barber shop but
like the whole thing I'm really thinking
about trying it because I don't mind I
don't like the [ __ ] little I'm
sensitive to all that [ __ ] your kuda
here or straight hair because curly hair
my beard so you get bulb stuff ya hate
that [ __ ] I'll hate that [ __ ] man I
gotta use a machine and not even get
actual shape but just trim it you know I
mean is what looks like a haircut
what you had to do is use a machine
first and then shave it with the little
blade comes out better I'm gonna try
that with the copper the one I did
before we're a dollar shave club just
got scissors but started cutting it is
right and then I like a haircut yeah I'm
out just shaving it on again I'll even
give you know yeah then I looked at
myself in the mirror I looked up Wow
like a [ __ ] dog booted off an
expansion I learned the hard way did not
to cut your own hair as a little kid
like I did it when my parents were gone
one day and I was I thought I was like
you know I was like how hard could it be
you know I could I just like [ __ ] up
my hair so bad there like there was a
bald spot like there was spots they was
like longer and I was I was pretty old
you know I was like [ __ ] nine and
[ __ ] maybe that's why I can't go here I
went out because I answered [ __ ] you dog
it does go just just not that long I was
apart of women who ever mustache you
know that they have a little mustache
growing they always say all she'll
probably play with her dogs with her
dad's razors
who the [ __ ] does that I never I never
gonna shave we're gonna be like the fat
puzzle is made to me never I never saw
shave my legs
yeah I never thought about that [ __ ] my
armpits Oh another kid I don't know why
bro Ally boss act like if you chicks
I'll give you like a [ __ ] it was too
hairy down there it's kind of sucks for
her and I can have I can have foot nah
man yeah I seen him in porn and poor boy
I don't know Mac and I don't know
wanting straight what man wants to shave
all his pubic hair man like why am I
talking about like [ __ ] like bald
shades I gotta like right that's like
way too much oh yeah wax that one yeah
yeah that we were talk about like well
you like balls I got a landscape dog
yeah I don't know about that one I
actually I don't know I thought that'd
be too much I still like my peanuts
itches already you know I don't want to
add an extra edge to it so he's a
bulldog you put Johnson global ball was
bad for you bro I heard it when I look
at it it causes our general to cancer
tacos also glad I never used and Sheena
commercial dog oh they are playing watch
the commercial in there is there they
have their own leaders johnson johnson
please call this number now yeah maybe
but it was said of it for you yeah I
didn't get like $5 multiple women man
they got testicular cancer ovarian
cancer like an ice-cream bar which I'll
go after yeah like why are you putting
like tacos on it like I mean I want you
don't with pampers you should be done
with it all right
21 you were gonna put a pepper what the
[ __ ] I'm baiting blow over here like
it's called taking a shower
no however I will use powder but it
would matter baby Johnson it was like
the one that's cold starch cuz my
[ __ ] oyster has a mean lost our bro
are you talking about - what they put on
babies and it's like that's like only
like I feel like we don't want edges
like what the babies is not everybody
enough yeah my sinister [ __ ] dawg
and then one is colder cookie - a true
you're like what I see have you I forgot
about that when I put it on my body
I forgot that they made up they make
what Mexican mouth to me a lot of it
yeah I totally I thought yeah yeah you
know that [ __ ] wasn't right with you
like oh I see [ __ ] pink hey my
birthday's like strawberry
like like what the [ __ ] anymore but you
can afford it issue what happened it
will forgive me Duncan Duncan Duncan
Hines brother I got a [ __ ] cake
growing here yeah he's like a powdered
sugar I think they're gonna eat us here
you like [ __ ] their butters me huh
oh man like when at the me rash one time
right I put a lot of baby powder man I
got the old drug I put too much I'm at
the airport and [ __ ] Gabriel and
spanks me real hard bro all that powder
just pops out of dusty everywhere right
that is that I was smuggling cocaine he
put you inside a bag open sir yeah damn
deep search so we were you from he's on
would you go up at I could upload
originality in my whole life man like I
lived like probably like close to USC my
whole life so when I was living in the
apartments of my family is like on
[ __ ] Kenwood which is like down the
street from USC and then like now I just
stay like five more minutes from there
to like expedition I used to live on ice
to live back in the days on Washington
and oak watch that downtown Elena you
stayed in the Union yeah because Union
yeah that's a live call to the Olympic
auditorium like to be my hangout another
game Wally's liquor store
wow that's right there on San Pedro yes
right yeah untreated zambales to you
yeah that's the only liquor store in the
area is that you gotta go to write it
because 7-eleven don't fall I know I
know a lobbies right Wally's Prague
Washington is right next to the the
other King taco ribbon yeah oh gee
that's original King Taco only King Taco
ever knew yeah Wally's nickels no more
dangerous clutch of flats hang out over
there man a flat for me yeah I was at
23rd come up my cousins a problem era
yeah uh West Side though okay
23rd Street and I'm I remember my cousin
if he got his blood he got he died
already but he got shot in a phase Eli
fool that [ __ ] [ __ ] he got it was
back then when he got is when he got
shot they were giving away money but
people got shot
victims of crime yeah like they'll give
her words so that for student he got
shot he got a settlement and they put
him on SSI at 22
to use city inside bro face got him set
for life yeah peachy sir he'll shout out
damn I don't even think at the end I
mean is he like his face cool what the
[ __ ] you say to school be just a little
yellow is a blue wire right here
wait did my coffee Julio died not sit
here huh
so sensual school he's like little blind
you know the world gets a little
chattery Jose Feliciano like Teddy walk
pretty walk yeah man [ __ ] imagine how
much I hadn't heard off like that would
you grew up at I grew up around that
area like going up Romero Flats area but
more towards like where the playboys is
that on the other side of [ __ ] was it
burning burning the main ring in San
Pedro area right there that's 40ml you
and you're from all a magical just name
the gang and they know you're at yep you
just name the gang you know it yeah man
we live abroad I live over there are now
Chris I live over there my heart beats
ok prize money I know that is my wish
huh that's a park over there right by
Hoover mmm yeah that's a partner no
Cooper Cooper yeah you're right we're
Hoover is like more yeah now water eh -
yeah Diego for a steady ac30 in streets
over there by that where you want to buy
the [ __ ] by the automotive and the
[ __ ] recycling bins yeah yeah yeah
you're right by HP yep yeah I'd like to
be my spotter than HP before they build
all the houses and Starbucks the only
burger place a to go to would and these
special burgers or super burgers and
ease on Santa Fe that's it you know the
closest spot this like right by my house
is like probably has like been there for
a while in his Burgesses tans or Thames
Kansas to Normandy and Jefferson right
there in that corner I remember like
when I realized what about my producer
like stays in those apartments behind
there and I realized that when I first
started clearing I was like dude I
wanted to record every day bro just week
eat at times sounds good
so you were in high school or here darle
yeah what is it uh ironically I [ __ ]
went to a K through 12 with such a big a
city so I didn't go there all the way
from like kindergarten though like I got
there from like 6 and then it was like
in sixth grade to 12 I went to Foshay
Learning Center and that's just like one
of those like like brothers history
school room like USD family of five
you know you get to like [ __ ] go on
the campus a lot and that [ __ ] was cool
dog with like I don't know I felt like I
got cheated from a real high school
experience I was like I had to play
tennis and soccer like what the [ __ ]
does I don't wanna play tennis so your
school the same school through your
whole career yeah pretty much
oh my god yeah it does like I didn't
like from sixth grade and on like it was
just like six to 12 it's like mad you
went to sue schools elementary and in
that school and I was in oh yeah just
went to elementary and then like middle
school and high school was the same [ __ ]
and I'm like man I gotta get used to
these [ __ ] like ass but if you
thought you were ugly its sixth grade
little - you're ugly at 12 a.m.
you're never gonna reinvent yourself but
you're gonna change schools bro
so you gotta be at the new guy new
school like they don't know you normal
loser those school but at least one
[ __ ] bad-ass I could reinvent myself
I'm a pop locker over here Oh luckily
was it too bad you know hung around a
good with a pretty decent crowd I mean
my friend were kind of like class clown
throughout the whole time so like we
could get away with it so it was like we
did you know I was like as long as it'll
get picked on dog we're good I went to
like elementary school Utah elementary
school up in Aliso village projects then
in sixth grade I went to second street
Hollenback also Reno Roosevelt and East
LA City College and then back to Robalo
hamper you went to a lot of school I
have a cousin like that except he got
kicked out of every single one of those
okay like anyway he made it was like I
was like Dawg you took it like homework
now he like went from Dorsey to Manuel
he lasted one day at Foshay and then he
was to LA hi he just kept going to every
single one and to like the whole
district like Almighty I like a you
can't have your son la district over
yeah we were septic another Hill High
yeah I know my deal was I won't go if
you want to I'm not [ __ ] driving you
way the [ __ ] over you over there
I want you put on people that that I
would like what happened bro oh man
there's a kick combo you don't need a
dog against on a date or I saw any me go
there you know that's exactly what it
was dog again with the fish especially
go by cuz it like he was during that
area I can do stupid [ __ ] like that all
the time for one time he showed up to
the house like I was like it was early
dismissal for me now show the running
dog like my grandma ain't know what the
[ __ ] was going on like so she was like
oh I'm just kind of like let my grandson
in they cook a meal and I like I like
foodies who came running for something I
remember I brought
a couple years later I was a you
remember that day he was like yeah he
was like my grandma save me from the
cops that day if I girl wanted to know
about that [ __ ] to this day dog he
showed up like running dodo you see the
skin-headed [ __ ] he just like
shirts all sweaty like it's like [ __ ]
pulled on there's a little blood stain
on it looking just like ready to the
house told my grandma he got released
early I was like my ass dog they should
be this guy though the crib at my junior
high school and it was Cornell Lewis he
was claiming rollin 60s but there's no
siree no but uh because he was
straight-up [ __ ] back we were in a bus
one time we passed by a neighborhood and
that food just took at hand I was a
c-note pacman bro going like this ha ha
- bunny off the bus and anyways I went
back to my junior high school in Harlem
back and then I started to on the first
day of school and I was like see I took
the advantage of going to a different
school while I was a big ass nerd and a
dork at all so you know judo has to go
into magnet classes yeah where - the
hard classes and I go back to Harlem
back then I see him come in at they're
all [ __ ] I get to hang out with a
coolest guy in this school every time so
I got to meet him before he went to any
class that was only last a week in
hollaback ma got kicked out
[ __ ] - chicks he told me that's why you
got come doubt it no man who came back
hard
I thought I was like damn we got kicked
ass with yanggaengie in gang banging
somebody has said with some chick and I
remember man I just say man that she has
pizzazz titties right then he told me
her says with her in the quad right off
hook to hook then I have to prove how
was just like that again my only open
thought nobody was looking
what would be in school you know what
though is always those troublemaker on
April the troublemaker kids be doing
that [ __ ] dog and Foshay there used to
be like the third floor they used to
have a stairway to the attic and during
like 56 periods I was like everybody who
like had like it was a couple or
whatever that's the spot they would go
to dog like everybody knew I'm like dog
this isn't like my hair like taking them
and I was like and they used that
staircase like a hotel room she really
goes down here high school too as she
goes down and every night I went to like
three different I scary how another or
older we know that our
Oh kids are now doing it huh I feel like
it's like I'm ten times worse though dog
like I did last year school I remember
this guy that was my neighbor that
[ __ ] with Jehovah Witness broke
he never came out of his [ __ ] house
but I school you the [ __ ] animal
right yeah but at home and the project
never came out bro it's weird like I
could just like everybody there's a
liquor store in my neighborhood that
everybody goes to I can tell you right
now and though in the 13 15 years that
kid lived there he did not walk even
halfway to the liquor store his mom
didn't let that fool out but he was
telling me this crazy [ __ ] story
about some other fool named cheater
was long hair and he said that there was
it one chick they were making out with
her and it took her to the pad it was
junior high yeah they took her to the
pad or no and then I those high
schoolers with the pad we rock 11th
graders he said to everybody she has sex
with everybody and she was like five
kids and I was a one girl and it was
what happened bro and then he was ten
with the crazy people have been all but
apples crazy dog after we're all done
just who went down on her ah man and he
said that he would like he'll play with
her hot dog
ah what a hot dog bro what a weenie in
and out a real hot but who played with
your furry little [ __ ] like that really
be happening man like I had an
experience it's like I felt like I was
in a porno right like alright so when I
was at homecoming like in high school I
ran for homecoming king I was like I
could win it [ __ ] what the food is
running is like some wax did you for 12
years both like Perot right yeah I was
like yeah I was like pretty fabulous
you're running against a guy who just
came into the school so like whatever
like you know that should happen you
know I would whatever in the next day
I'd known this girl for like since like
elementary dog and I'd always known she
was like a wild chick right she's
talking with my homegirl and then like
like I'm telling you like hey come here
and I was like oh so did I go to next
class was like yeah and then they're
like oh well you wanna go [ __ ] and I'm
like I thought they were joking you know
I was like straight up like that and I
was like haha they told you no but my
friend from Mike Elementary like told me
that straight up and I was like other
nice is like a joke they're like whoa
will text you when we're in front of the
school because we're in the thousand
third floor and this
like the entrance of the school right
here so like I went to class thinking I
was like this [ __ ] is [ __ ] she must
have been high on some [ __ ] whatever so
like I'm in class maybe thirty minutes
in the class I was disruptive as [ __ ]
class like I had to set every single
class I had to sit by myself next to the
air conditioner like next to the window
like every ti every one of my teachers
knew like these this is he just pulls a
fine seat in every classroom away from
like the rest of the civil humans so I
get a text message and I look out the
window and it's like my barber my
homegirl my other two homegirls in it
and it was like yo you come in and I'm
like fog dawg so I started to fake a
stomach ache dog I faked it my teacher
is happy as [ __ ] to send me the [ __ ] out
I walk out we go to the [ __ ] you know
we go like to her house and we start
walking like the whole time we're like
literally you know talking and I and I
told my I was talking to my barber and I
was like a dog you think this is gonna
go down with a bull [ __ ] and it's like
oh we're like she has a house to herself
and I was like damn fool I was like
yelling I was in like high early high
school right and I'm like I'm getting
nervous the closer we're getting to the
house right like I'm like man I wonder
dog her [ __ ] Tia's in the living room
right so we walk in it's [ __ ] it's a
crowd fool it's a crowd it's like
probably four girls and me and my boy
okay [ __ ] pop-up like literally dog
like we're going in like in food she has
a baby in the same room fish it it we
thought yeah yeah we walk in there hey
when I started like wrong whatever good
kids is good we go into the room it is
[ __ ] locks the door right she pulls out
a [ __ ] bottle of brandy from under
her sister's bed and she's like here
drink some relax bro like in a matter of
like maybe like 20 minutes like my
homegirl tells her like oh like so start
getting to it I'm like like what the
[ __ ] you guys are gonna watch also
instead of watching the homie starts
[ __ ] the other girl in has your
sister's bed so I like we're on this bed
and like my homies with homegirl on this
bed and no homo no homegirls is left out
just like watching bro
and I'm like bro this is the most crazy
[ __ ] happened in high school dogs my
Barbara will [ __ ] verify his story
whenever he cuts whatever hairs leftover
are you [ __ ] what's left the one on my
face about it but to feel like that
probably crazy [ __ ] I'm like Dawg if we
did that off for such a small [ __ ]
community when we were like
I can I don't know what was like 16 17
like a smoke really imagine the [ __ ]
that goes on in schools like la Hache
like they be surprised our [ __ ] [ __ ]
fast [ __ ]
you lucky dog and that was nothing like
that happen to me bro I just hurt me -
but her story bro not like me either
I'm just bad at it there was one chick I
remember I will come another I told her
swimming class at 6:00 in the morning to
7:00 then I come out then I come back
and take another swimming class to open
a swimming team I just got lucky man I
don't even try out I just have a tomato
swim team there was this chick that I
knew from junior high and I kind of like
just go to party chick right but you
don't have a chance I have [ __ ] long
hair or her own orz shirt you know do
you know who that was it was a major
legit oh [ __ ] me boy if I had a [ __ ]
um Judas Priest t-shirt bra because that
means I went to the concert she's in my
cou but um she was my height I remember
her man
it was pretty with my shirt as tall as
me pretty mad pretty
I remember her boobs come I don't back
then I remember man she had a fire now
but um she was just she was stopped
being I was going out of the pool and
she was coming in to change like with
her sweater backpack and her clothes
right and she would just say hi to me oh
just stop me hey were you going so I'm
going back to my class overly friendly
stop because she want to talk to me
again yeah like me but I liked her too
but I didn't know how to take it to the
next level you know I was in a comedian
back then you know she didn't see the
team to perform so I ignored her then
another 10 she will come and she'll wait
wait wait and she gave me a hug and a
kiss and a cheek then she just stopped
me and I never talked to her but I
wanted to talk to her but I already late
to my class dog right so let's call it
later on I hope I see my friend Adam he
were from this gang or not really a gang
it was like a football team a crew they
were called the hill here from the hill
and they will Adam and he live a double
[ __ ] Hill and then he was telling me
I would ended up talking to him and that
fool told me that that chick how words
with house
I guess that week or in another she went
to a house and they showed up with 40
ounces per like Old English Mickey's and
they're just parting them to drinking
and he told me those tricks made out
well and they got naked and they were
all fooling around but I was like [ __ ]
man I could have been me man any and
John [ __ ] could have been me and I
hated my life till then and I said what
the [ __ ] is wrong with me mad [ __ ]
would being handed to me and a [ __ ]
super platter in a river he hearted I
didn't see it it was like [ __ ] sir
would you like a [ __ ] now I'm good I
will a [ __ ] and I forgot [ __ ] though
like I'm saving my marriage thank you
yeah man yeah I'm waiting for I went to
I'm willing to meet somebody get a
pregnant to ruin my life about brown it
could have been her those are the most
regretful like it went after High
School's over and then you get like a
Facebook message or inst recurrences
[ __ ] laughs I used to have a crush on
you and you're like now you're telling
me that yeah you're like you is like
where your eye twitches a little bit
you're like you know what a community
talked I got this [ __ ] how I tried
[ __ ] you wouldn't even having it you
will not give me the time I dare you
three kids to realize you like me yeah
like it's sexy three kids in two
different days I try to measure how like
how I measure how long like I've been
out of high school and [ __ ] like if I
look at my like peers on Facebook and
it's only on Facebook because like all
the people that [ __ ] up stayed on
Facebook and everyone on Instagram or
snapchat you can tell how long you been
out of high school but but you start
reading your friends ailments what
- [ __ ] sickle-cell huh that's
for you to play tetherball with me yeah
for real like u vz+ be getting sick now
like for real like losing a [ __ ]
party off yeah like who's be getting
sick Donovan you're like you see foods
like that I've seen its essentia like AI
have gout like what the [ __ ] they be
like [ __ ] the oysters yeah like what are
you Bobby Hill yeah okay - huh yeah I do
it's in my finger the middle one says
Doug like from this apart I just like a
mug shot of Bobby good I have a lot of
cars cartoon tattoos man - [ __ ]
tattoo artists with me waiting for a
while who's happy having Elvis huh yeah
you miss out a lot of high school [ __ ]
I missed out on I'm playing because I
was a [ __ ] I was a scholar like he
also [ __ ] baseball place a lot of a
shy boy love baseball so I had to get my
grades you know I mean just to play so
look at you now oh man I didn't graduate
I mean for most people you know they
went to like three different high
schools because they got down with
people or they tagged on [ __ ] you know I
went to three different high schools
because I was gonna play baseball and
[ __ ] well actually go to I went first I
went to uh Thomas Jefferson in the hood
Jefferson High School yes you know mr.
mr. Richard Allen teach you the history
old Jewish guy now I never had mr. Allen
but you know who that is yeah the Jewish
brother who I used to work started a hot
dog with that [ __ ] he saw peanut
at Dodger Stadium right oh really
yeah Richard Allen yeah he still does
that yeah he got married to one of his
do this what yeah he got married to
whatever stood in for Jefferson High um
and um but he told me that we have we
start doing it too after high school
believe it oh well hell I didn't it
[ __ ] bro bro hell no yeah how are
you totally man he never dollar together
right and then me and I didn't see him
for a long-ass time
he was so tubing Philippe she left me
yeah cuz I she left him for a guy that
was working with him a younger guy of
course oh how well how much older was
this for the magic like what was all in
my mom of course yeah she got tired of
the old really 60 something years old
now and she she's probably nearing
barely 40 now or 38 yeah you know what
I've seen that [ __ ] happen so many times
like with no issues no no no we're
teachers but like I'll talk about like a
general like you see food they're like
like let's say a high school or like you
knew it like a hot chick they had an
older boyfriend and like if you would've
known how I was gonna pan out and you
could have like time to write you
probably would have had that rebound
chance because you know that she's not
gonna work out now you're like what's
your 19 and this [ __ ] is like 36 like
you don't want to get married in
nineteen no the high school do the girl
whose 60s future just like she'll the
older woman already brought the corn is
blow high he'll hear that I'll guarantee
no it's going down the hallway nice
pants
and she was like 16 years old she was um
I'm in row so I was talking to her as
well as gum and she goes my boyfriend
pick me up if I got a car yeah you said
you like she was proud to say it - she's
2615 [ __ ]
but back then you don't know about um
the age that that's wrong right because
I could have told her [ __ ] I'm a couple
cops and I [ __ ] [ __ ] ripping
that [ __ ] up ha ha ha ha no ferrari's
right though that's what you think
you're like damn dog I'm not plenty of
women that are don't hold your my first
thought was when she told me that [ __ ] I
can't wait to be 26
that's what's that I don't know maybe
ride my head damn a 16 year old at 26
like they're for real like if it but
that's what you think at that age you're
like damn man I wish I could be that
older be older bad and then we get older
you're like [ __ ] that and you know that
should didn't last
you're right didn't last no it never
does bro like there's many occasions
like I've been in situations where like
what is it like you have to compete with
like the boyfriend she's been with for
like eight years right whatever you're
like there and then like they get back
like she gets back with him and they
like you just go make some popcorn like
I made it I just sat back and I'm not
gonna go make some popcorn I was like
almost watch this go down I was like it
took a year later for that top corner
bead of but I called it dog - it was
done with like and what happens as soon
as it's done my [ __ ] snapchat lights
up oh yeah I was like eh alert alert
well that it only woman you've been with
she can go this um I'll say 36
how are you ten twenty five twenty five
yeah yeah we would be the red but now I
think I was like Lane today actually
yeah she was 36
if you feel older - you like all [ __ ] I
mean she she didn't seem like too old
but she seemed experienced some of the
best sex of my life I'll say that doc
don't get me started I was a little
[ __ ] tell you what right now this was
like I [ __ ] just put like for some
reason dog I just don't pull nothing for
like older ones dogs like when I was 18
dog Mike the girlfriend I was seeing was
26 like when I was 18 in high school
she'll pick me up like senior year and
[ __ ] like that oh this woman out there
was 40 years old or
yeah how are you probably like 2 years
ago so I'm like my 25 damn yeah my baby
mama was 9 years older in me yeah you
ain't together man nothing to brag about
9 years older and 90 pounds lighter me
I've been in a relationship where like
the person is like 7 years older in
microphone cash it's a big difference
dog like a real [ __ ] like that [ __ ] like
it's cool when like your own for the
first two months and [ __ ] like that but
then when she starts getting serious and
they start like hey I'm trying to like
lock you down and they share you start
seeing like the [ __ ] boa constrictor
grip on you and me before you know it
you're like that dude and then the condo
about to get eaten and you're like I
ought to [ __ ] come on like you go
save I've liked Brody just like you're
watching your life just get drained out
of you like a [ __ ] empty toothpaste
thing you'll be a shows man and you
think that that the girl's dad bring her
to a show but now that's her man oh yes
how would I would look at that mannequin
know we're working with Mike Epps and I
would see like a young black young woman
yo she's what black woman no matter what
color but you could tell you know we're
probably are the same age or she's 30
but her old man's like 56 and I always
think about it when I see an older man a
young girl take [ __ ] pies to
whipser
how it looks like a like a father and
daughter relationship I just look at out
like last resort huh I'm I couldn't make
it out huh like didn't work out for you
that's what I think about when I'm like
man there's no way that she's real dawg
I mean maybe there might be a few cases
where that [ __ ] might be like legit it's
not no [ __ ]
daintiness and [ __ ] like that but when I
look at it sometimes I was like damn and
your your goal didn't plan out on mmm
you needed that security blanket huh oh
yeah man I need me a roof yeah you need
somewhere to stay steady count cool hey
living in the hood man like epital that
it might hood like you will see food
that just got locked up no food that got
released from prison and they have
nowhere to go now because the mom don't
want them so you food hook up with the
earlier chicken oh yeah
I've seen that [ __ ] with that one the
fat one was three kid and her man locked
up - yep I seen that [ __ ] way too many
times you're like two handful you're
just like getting a crossfire like you
just you went from a [ __ ] like a
negative environment have been a better
option does like coke what dollar a
month instant family get it get a
[ __ ] job gets you know what I've had
water I've seen I've seen [ __ ] it I've
had homies dog like homies that I like
stepped into something like that and I'm
like dog like she already had two
trophies like and they ain't yours like
like no dog it's like it's you're into
it if you're not ready for it and like
and sure enough when I've seen home
either come back and be like [ __ ] like a
dog my job to my cousin got me nephew
got a chick with two kids already social
a fool he is a baby lottery where he's a
scratcher he's are you guys okay look
like and then he added three three more
to that and then they broke up and then
she had another kid with another dude so
she has six kids with three different
daddies shouting [ __ ]
damn that's a [ __ ] heavy car fact
well that's your Barbie when a couple is
here with somebody right and you have
your kid you have two kids together you
break up you come back together she
comes back pregnant and you got someone
else pregnant - [ __ ] happens man that's
crazy that's like [ __ ] tying your
shoes together dog ha ha ha you know
like you're like like little ball sued
yeah like you're gonna like no matter
how slow you walk it's gonna take one
little step - just [ __ ] boom the
manager took me Oh craziest story man
who's that singer like that that he
ended up on ticket hooking up with
somebody then I pushed it came back with
kids and they both died now he's
watching kids aren't even his Bob killed
off what happened yeah that's [ __ ]
and then he dies my god sir
yeah so now you're watching tears there
aren't even his walk I'm surprised with
all that [ __ ] he did die to dog [ __ ]
it's like me myself and Irene died he's
like the father to three black kids then
are his because his wife took off but
they loved him anyway
shout to Jim Carrey the fool smart oh
yeah they're geniuses yeah if I could do
that I don't I don't I don't know if I
could do that I got it takes a bit I
think I'm a little bit like even at this
age I was like man am I too selfish to
think about a kid like I'm so excited
right now and I'm like you know what
like I like the attention like it's good
like I'm not I'm not am I trying to
share that yet bro
hell no bro it just changed the whole
life your whole schedule changer on the
kid that's why I always tell ladies man
on Facebook if you don't want to live a
life of poverty don't have care 2:30 now
or 35 people start driving okay right
now you could keep a pic about it man
but nobody gonna watch that [ __ ]
for you we're going to work but then
they get they get that a they get that
like once they get 35 and or like what
certain age like women start panicking
bro like they start panicking that
shit's like [ __ ] like a fish coming
out of water bro sure you start doing a
35 year old bro no bro hey I don't even
start telling you bro
what the [ __ ] we're doing right now I
just got our man I just told you that
Brian I don't even so much I had to deal
with that [ __ ] so bad I have somebody
pretty much like literally like trying
to change my lifestyle I override I'm
like I love the chick problem I goddamn
like why the [ __ ] you want a kid in 35
there's my god because when the baby
turns 20 will be 55 and you'll be 47
you'd be right I'll be a Silver Fox
yeah I could walk out I have no kids now
I got no kids
thankfully nope no kids you guys are
lucky but you're a rare breed right well
and we're Latino you know it your friend
we just came back from you from Europe
this was like you guys should go to
Europe you guys will be like unicorns
out there yeah she's like you like
something different we don't exist out
there in Amsterdam anyway yeah it's all
bad for reals I went to Amsterdam
Rotterdam and I'm I met these these dumb
okay guys from Rotterdam
and so we were smoking and I told him
well from man you're from East LA or the
hood an hour late once you go to am
rotterdam yeah you have [ __ ] you
ranked bro he goes man you have stripes
already bros like automatic they bow
down when you come to your town to go
there with a fresh haircut pull that guy
that guy was was old he was quoting
blood and blood out in a Dutch accent I
got you a schema for real doc they love
blood in blood out way I think I saw
that what did you do that a while back
you posted a video of like two twins or
somebody from there from Austria from
Morocco
yeah like Muslim growth and you're
quoting of the line another dad Dan
that's crazy you know what all that
[ __ ] culture is that that's how the
culture influences a lot like I saw a
video of like fools in Asia they're like
straight like look like bangers dog
they're right-handed and they're like
straight line Oh homey dogs like me our
chairs and cookies yeah Krista the
problem is that we don't show up when
the movie comes out though we wait to
convert on video yeah like I could say
right now I didn't go see lowrider I
didn't see it I mean I still out there I
should pay two million dollars and 357
theaters that that is that low I have no
idea I think I sprayed also pretty good
right and I'm a total number nine movie
how much did it cost to make that movie
couldn't a cosmic I'm thinking like a
lot really high budget movie and it was
made with a begin certificate it was
made by students in college yeah
estudiantes and funny man when you watch
a movie like a lowrider just hit a movie
lowrider
or any movie that has Latinos in it and
you're a you're like a somewhat
celebrity or you're known like I'm known
as a ton a comedian but why do we treat
you a Bronco you learn a [ __ ] movie
dog like I have a choice in this don't
you think I would've wanted rip the
other very carpet [ __ ] like I
push it a hill ahead of you bro I bro
you [ __ ] you couldn't get be real in it
yeah I get that all the [ __ ] what
happened [ __ ] is our choice I've said
the funniest [ __ ] I've said to some eyes
I hold on let me pull that [ __ ]
out of my pocket for you dawg here you
go down ask him yourself
yeah people dick - here like
whenever like they see like other [ __ ]
go on in the community and then how come
you didn't do that event I'm like
[ __ ] does it look like I'm
putting it together like I would love to
be on that roster but yeah it's it's
[ __ ] it's like that sometimes
[ __ ] don't understand is how
you have to go out there do some [ __ ] to
me over the last tear you saw Felipe
Esparza wearing a Pendleton around ever
Longoria at the other can't say Eric I
recall that man never Bible didn't
choose me it shows my hood but not me
if you wanted made American meat I was
there I was like now than the other
rehab when they were shooting at moving
damn around I would have been in that
[ __ ] to tell people from the
neighborhood in that movie yeah yeah my
friend wasn't my friend did all those
tattoos for blood and blood out but a
real tattoo they're all henna rentals -
I have to do is three dots that she was
shot in my neighborhood but do a micro
mouth lips yeah my friend Miguel house
yeah that's the her and then after that
they knock down the project's what that
gentrification going down nah those
progeny to go they own they knock them
down and they made more projects yeah
they were getting rid of the coke
courtyard Estrada cords looking projects
oh that's like the project where I grew
up and look at the projects from B&E and
hazard yeah that's what this really did
in Chicago with those big-ass Hightower
[ __ ] yeah that's a big Gator ones oh
yeah like they literally took all them
down because like the whole thing would
be is like they were as long as the cops
would come at their training they were
all we do is run upstairs like about a
ton I get upstairs I feel like the [ __ ]
is going to stop him when I was over in
Chicago I passed by those projects and
those a guy who told me that no man the
[ __ ] was
snipers up there and wind up on the hood
oh shoot you from way up there and
they'll have shootouts with the other
projects and then he goes go to the
police go to the fire station go look at
the wall and I want to live with the
wall man that's [ __ ] wall full of
holes dog [ __ ] just from people shooting
over each other snipers on without
gangsters in your neighborhood
hanging I mean I'll tell you but less
carnico they feel gangbanging enemy hey
as it used to be yeah that they still
gangbang this food still you see them at
night writing on the walls and [ __ ] yeah
I just think that's what happened I was
like when I grew it when I grew up I can
the nice because I grew up and I'm like
a I said I can make sure of like the
crypts and like a harpies neighborhood
so like I like good wine my neighborhood
where I live is like it's predominantly
Crips so like I I just kind of didn't
see I did see it you would see the cops
folder so not 30 script stories yeah
like so rollin thirties yeah yeah so
like this would just kind of just kick
it there like and I already knew I was
like it my mom who is like he's like a
like leave those guys alone you know
like nothing nailed to maternity leave
me home yeah that kind of [ __ ] you know
so don't read you'd have to [ __ ] walk
like you know passed these fools to go
to the school and like I don't know they
never [ __ ] said anything all I ever
heard from them was like what's up could
like that's all I ever heard from them
like I guess the fact that they saw me
with a backpack that anybody [ __ ] with
me you might like it the description
yeah I didn't fit the description or
whatever but yeah like I did see a lot
of this [ __ ] the craziest [ __ ] I ever
saw go down in the neighborhood there's
two things now it goes one time with
these apartments like two houses like in
front like from where like where I live
like cops came one day I think somebody
was barricading themselves like two cops
busted out that shotgun they have in the
car and started blasting at the windows
dog like and everybody got a letter the
next day thing and like an apology for
what happened that was before she had
happen and then the other time this
crazy and [ __ ] that happened this is the
craziest [ __ ] dog
so three [ __ ] young [ __ ]
right pull up in a bike this is my house
next door pull up in a bike like one of
these little foods cause the SWAT in the
[ __ ] forest what are then shoots him
and all three of them take out in a bike
in the spur Dan and murk that for that
kid was like fifteen so I was like damn
and I was leaving the house at that time
dog you're like what oh [ __ ] so I was at
homeboy industries at the silkscreen
house their orders from shirts I just
one last comic standing was 2011 I was
there with Lisa and little me claw her
son he was young you were like 5 or 6
years old over Ito blond hair blue eyes
she's just on the floor playing with his
cars right where we're waiting for
shirts and the guy helping me he's I
know here I grew up with him I know his
brothers he's to gangbang to the other
guy to gangbang to
pretty much everybody was helping me in
that homeboy heal silkscreen you to
gangbang so man these two fools come in
with hoods under on their faces and with
we have bananas right bandanas here and
they were kind of dirty and they were
like they just rush in there right and I
trying to open this door to all the
employees are at but it won't open and
he looks at me and he looks down at
Isaac plain and the fools are they
[ __ ] bone out they leave right and
that's what they left I asked a guy
working there he goes I'm lucky yet
there's no gas masks so these guys
they're gonna bring in brilliant that
bad air because I thought they were
employed yeah all dirty
they never looked at me like a ghost he
just ran dog my [ __ ] ran and left was
there he left us there right and then he
ran and then he called for the he called
for the great Boyle listen man these
fools keep in here trying to blast our
body so the pellet heading to the bakery
let everybody know and I think I'm not
feeling kinda [ __ ] cops didn't call
they didn't tell nobody where we almost
has been in a [ __ ] gang style massacre
right now ah fool this was came in ready
to kill somebody bro they came in
holding their hand like this
they have been Donna's and they try to
break into the employees a rat but we
were like in the office waiting and then
thou fool just took off running I pretty
sure there was no child there we
probably all been shot
Wow there is some pretty much meatloaf
or you might say we go pro see the
daytime damn that's why man you don't
give back to the community that's like I
had a good huh that's why you don't give
back to the community and also I wonder
the food if it was a personal be for
those who were just mad that this wasn't
like not about that life no more oh no
man they had shot one if you know
because those guys who got shot a person
got shot where I grew up a week ago he
got shot you know he got shot I grew up
with
I know the kid he got smoked so that was
a and then they found out I get at the
guy that shot him but his home is work
at this particular homeboy silkscreen oh
damn
yeah so it was it was premeditated yeah
yeah retaliation but let's just get
anybody bro start to closest that should
be happening more than you think just
cause it's not televised yeah getting
begging is still going strong
yeah it is more organized art you know
you know what movie painted they're
pretty good and the watch yeah yeah that
movie [ __ ] got it on point because
all those neighborhoods it's like I'm
like man I Drive through those
neighborhoods like I'm like I'm doing
that I've driven through the house
before like the house where they bust
out illegals I was like I know where
that house is that dog I got driven by
it I'm like that's where all those food
came out and like all those like illegal
foods are tied up and [ __ ] that's just
crazy that's how I think that's how the
organized crime yeah man and then when I
first took that gun out to that cop I so
don't give a [ __ ] yeah I don't really
think that's like the really [ __ ] that's
real [ __ ]
yeah cuz in Mexico that's how they
probably would have done it like
[ __ ] matter of fact and make or
they wouldn't have been no cop going up
stop in this [ __ ] forwardable I
let that [ __ ] go dawg here we
know dr. Charlie know in a [ __ ] Chevy
Silverado let that [ __ ] go now
even it was not a dirty cop he knows not
to [ __ ] with dirty cops money yep yeah
real [ __ ] that's how crazy it is and you
know what I've been like I written like
I like to vacation to make all I got I
go into like no that's like a spot I
like for futures there right yeah I was
there like for my birthday last year and
like I was out in a resort and Cabos and
stuff like that let me tell you doc you
get the feel enough is like everything
is like ran by these [ __ ] dawg
like there's like there was some [ __ ] I
saw good there was a couple things go
down so first of all the resort dawg
it's like a round it's like it's called
Mahalo [ __ ] plant it goes to the
[ __ ] swamps or whatever so this is
like diamond ass [ __ ] resort and like
outside of butter is like wow [ __ ] look
couple Gators outside like and it's like
the one road and like sometimes you
might see the Gators up in the front
you're like okay that's like strike one
number two off of a night of partying
there there was a dude with a very
fluorescent Gucci shirt mustache blinged
out had like 20 heads inside this club
there's karaoke night he
had like some fine chick she's like
finally I got a Portela dog like real
[ __ ] I gotta go like report that a
finance chick right there and this will
got a key so he's [ __ ] ticking
everyone in his posse he's like oh you
dance you sing this song you do this and
we're watching this go down I like and
he's like everything he says goes he
goes to the DJ play that song three
times a DJ plays it and then I'm right
there with the girl was with and whether
they were there for another couple and
this [ __ ] trying to get it the
other dudes like girl and he will not
give it up like he's persistent bro like
he did not give a [ __ ] like in the other
dude didn't really know what to say cuz
he seemed 20 [ __ ] Mexicans up in
there like and this was a dress like
[ __ ] like you know what I mean like
straight bollard out and like he seems
like he ran the [ __ ] dog here like the
next day or dudes like walking out with
two duffel bags and there was a [ __ ]
Ferrari in the [ __ ] resort where
there's nothing but dirt like nothing
but dirt road around [ __ ] alligators
dog
that shit's [ __ ] deep out there dog
it's looking crazy like you have to
[ __ ] people to be from the u.s. to
notice that kind of [ __ ] out there I
think they don't [ __ ] know the sick
they're so used to it that I only want
to notice they will get killed for that
the huge noise by the way huh if you
thought yeah who the [ __ ] puts a Ferrari
in the [ __ ] middle of like a [ __ ]
like rough undeveloped rose [ __ ] like
[ __ ] like this like the Nissan Versa
barely made it there and there's like
Gators everywhere like who puts a
[ __ ] like God like I expensive car
like that it was a brand new one to dog
like all muddy and [ __ ] you're like that
suspension itself you probably paid cash
or room it was like he look like he look
like a like a Mexican Super Mario dog
like that mustache he's got that little
gut
he had that hair to the back of Cabo San
Lucas not that that was in Cancun so
they're pretty much organized I like
they all like they don't not to [ __ ]
around with the tour's errata yeah like
I feel like they just go there to just
like clear collect money or just like
let that [ __ ] go I was I want to be
surprised at the resorts are owned by
them to be honest with you like I would
not be surprised like it would because
that's a lot like the way [ __ ] is out
there you talked to a couple employees
and [ __ ] like sure you can get whatever
you want out there like they have [ __ ]
set up like shops and [ __ ]
good food hell yeah my favorite thing to
go to Mako for is [ __ ] seafood like a
lot of people I love each other
dog I [ __ ] like I will somebody tells
me a if you go to the spot this [ __ ]
tooth like [ __ ] two hours away and
it's the best ever eat are you gonna
have I'm gonna go there and have Sarita
in my eight beers you'd love to meet you
understand VJ you know somebody to go to
the beaches part man I kind of like it
but I'm not used to having like a whole
shrimp article are what Chile oh it's so
good other HP this big place was a close
up I don't know man
well I know that they watch cars on the
side too oh I know what you're talking
about you yeah every time on Sundays is
like super PAC yeah I know exactly what
you're talking about they have good eye
watching I don't know the name of it but
like my [ __ ] brothers wife [ __ ] a
pixel food from there on Sundays and she
goes early dog like early and I like our
Chile's oh my gosh it's bomb but that
[ __ ] will leave your [ __ ] lips like
[ __ ] picante and [ __ ] you like spicy
food yeah I do yeah
I can't I like crazy food but it's like
I got a really love it for me to put up
with a guy I don't like like [ __ ]
sweating on time like what I used to
work tomorrow one time and I became
friends with this like any dude work to
the kiosk
suit mockery one time right and I never
tried Korea Milo dude tell me why I
[ __ ] spent like the last hour just
like in the back room just like oh my
god I'm talking about Indian food when
they say medium or hot that [ __ ] means
don't [ __ ] get the medium bro medium
is [ __ ] ah he was like it is not that
hard my name is barking ha ha I'm like
this [ __ ] is [ __ ] a hot dog let's tie
red tie and Indian food could be pocket
for something holiday Mexican pool here
yeah we don't just Park it just put
chili just to [ __ ] it all up yeah I
don't ya know that's like that's I feel
like that's what I got it I was like wow
would you like that level of spices
that's keeping shake like is that to
keep in shape or to sweat it out or
something but you know what though after
you do sweat out all that [ __ ] by the
chill I just kind of feel like you're
like oh did I talk to myself or what
your shirts all like drenched in show
you like why didn't you I did this [ __ ]
make me sway it's like taking a big dab
you know how about you you get a snap
sweats if you take a really good dab in
the [ __ ] look at you what was so is
[ __ ] um hot ass hoochie chicks try to
do devs are [ __ ] Instagram bro
they're trying to get they'll do it for
the ground on you know to get free dad
yeah three dabs of gimme let me tell you
doctor they had a cocaine cup and they
were giving out free coke [ __ ] will
be doing rounds I'm sorry
yeah them long ago spoon bro looks like
they would be doing the same [ __ ] just
different drugs the fact that this is so
like it's like you know at all in like
you see the [ __ ] a lot in these events
and we've seen it before because we were
going to these events when there was
nothing but dudes there yeah I like I
can add a like there's nothing but I was
here all of a sudden like I don't know
where it's like they started looking
through Instagram I started waking up
saying hey these [ __ ] weed heads are
making some money and all of a sudden
you see the flock they be coming into
peacocking and [ __ ] like we deal with
this [ __ ] all the [ __ ] time like I've
had people I have a chicks try to
approach me just like they could try to
go ahead and come kick it at the studio
already like try to people try to be
backstage to kick it it would be a [ __ ]
yeah
you smell that [ __ ] from a mile away
you're like no [ __ ] curved how'd you
get started be real TV you guys
this fool is there before me though I
wrote it it's a college uh pretty much I
mean for the short period you know
you're like a penguin so this well yeah
I read most of all this shows actually
there I do what this guy desert bring
like yeah exactly what he does so that's
a lot shows every day huh yeah Monday
through Friday and we find it at be real
TV WWE TV and it's Monday to Friday we
got shows that shows every hour or our
first show is that uh I believe it's
like 9:00 in the morning we got like we
have DJ Eddie be swift in New York we
got different locations and then we have
the dr. greenthumb show at 1:00 o'clock
it update will be real you've been on
there and you guys have the Cadillac
smoke us about that right oh yeah we got
the actually bug it we switched up now
it's a he bought a Chevy Impala night
with a Caprice a glasshouse lowrider so
it's a new one I don't know if you
haven't been in that one right no I woke
in the catalyzer do a part two dog
I got to come back and get another one
in the new car yeah you guys do it
before so by before September 30 cuz I
would have my HBO special comes out you
know what i'ma see if I can talk to that
fool about that that way you can you can
talk about that in the smoke box
I really thought for a long time that
they were driving bro let's watch that
show are you watching a stone yeah
watch it on TV but now they can be
driving be real can be driving like that
amigo oh you finally get out like
they're done Oh like you don't know who
that all eternity legal way dude that
that car is gets pretty [ __ ] smoke
you like we've seen people come out of
there like way too smoked out we see
people like hop out before the Indians
yes has been a come there's been a
couple people that like when that
happens what happens in the video cause
I ain't yeah yeah like they put an X
over them yeah it's like that how many
people know how to smoke like that like
they're not used to it they say like
I've had people come from other states
and say they could smoke and they come
over here you give them a little bit of
some of us and like all guys be real
ever been to a play with her no weed
I've been to a lot of places man What
did he say I cut it on Felipe Esparza
What did he say today the two places
that he did that what is it he won't
even think about any or lindsay.wood no
Dubai no he said yeah [ __ ] the bike and
go there he said he said what is it the
Middle East and [ __ ] Asia he said
those are the two player chatter [ __ ]
head off he's like he's like he's like
he wouldn't try to even [ __ ] try to
play the dog is for Japan Singapore the
Philippines though oh yeah holy [ __ ]
crazy
it featured alligators here dog if your
drug addict real [ __ ] the presidents out
of his [ __ ] mind that is crazy like
this will has like drug militias like
he'd be making like public threats
talking about he's gonna eat his enemies
livers like crazy
he's like some psycho [ __ ] what's so
cool you guys been coming up man
hell yeah man we do got a couple things
coming up
listen everybody y'all want to come yep
so pretty much July 7th to the 9th we
just confirmed this today the biggest
hash Festival in California or I would
say right now in the world chalice is
going to be going down and your boys we
don't smoke the same which is chica
Delic and myself will be performing on
the main stage we will have a booth for
all our emerge in all our Terps and
aside from that it's gonna be a very
good time because like I said this is
the world's biggest hash festival it's
[ __ ] challenge and so I want to say
this is a biggest show yet for us yeah
but you also perform the rap group right
yeah that's a group we don't smoke the
same so like they booked this is a group
and will I go we're excited about that
and follow our instagrams
for giveaways because we're going to be
giving away tickets all month long these
150 dollar tickets too by the way like
these are three day pass day passes yeah
like this shit's like legit wow you got
fun there bro like you like yeah I'm
gonna get you up in the co-inventor if
you have time to company but um this is
definitely one of these one of these
events you don't want to miss out I
honestly think it's going to be bigger
than High Times to be honest if I had to
say if I had to say something or it's
going to be right around that level but
yeah make sure you look out for that and
those are going to be a big rival not
really oh yeah Vic remove the second
time
do you know license I believe what is it
they will have doctors on site just like
right at the entrance if you don't have
it and there is there is some like some
some leverage to that whole to the whole
legalization because I know some people
what's your 21 and like yeah yeah and
I'm not sure that's the case we get to
certain places once you're 21 you can
just give them your ID
this has happened every year because a
little tunnel remember last year I think
this is like the fourth one this is a
fourth year third something like that
it's pretty it's pretty brand new child
July 7th through the 9th what's it
called chalice music festival very well
there's music festival detail their
challenge is the biggest hash Festival
it's called challenge California music
class hash and art so people come by a
three-day pass if they want any day pass
so they could watch our guys I will try
to get her because we're gonna be
leaving them everywhere you might just
leave them like somewhere around here
burbank and you do a lot of I know that
you do a lot of those like what louis
xiii does you get you put on every once
in a while you hide a little stash for
somebody yeah but that's exactly what
we're gonna do in some a tickets that's
awesome you get do that I might do that
and I have something I'd be hiding weed
sometimes you know like because I
recently started doing my collabs with
flavors like you got your own brand yeah
like I have my holy my Ulta yeah I've
actually brought this for you
some it's my Italian wedding so this is
uh what is it pretty much like what I do
is like I have my company called flavors
biiis own and I do a lot of
collaborations with different companies
whether that's like a glass company a
weed company a dab company whatever you
make is long a candle company whatever I
can go ahead and we can work together
and try to push out and do some quality
work we will do it so like this one is
called Italian Wedding the reason is
called Italian Wedding because the two
strings to make it is gelato bread with
wedding cake
and that makes Italian wedding and
that's under my collaboration with dad
bath which is a you know the company
that grows is I also have other [ __ ]
like I have my puff pen email candles
which is uh you know the candles they
all have a pendant inside which is like
a really big part of our culture because
a lot of [ __ ] be buying like
pretty heady like glass you know I mean
like some of these glass chains and some
of these glass rigs are worth like it's
like cars but what is that buffalo
dabbing now this is this is just fashion
it's like the necklace so it's like what
I did it's my boy empty one glass made
me this this pendant with my logo this
is like my main logo like my cookies
logo like but it's free zone and yeah
it's pretty much like it's pretty much
like that and uh like I just try to go
ahead and get my hands on everything I
can but as long as I supportive so like
I have [ __ ] like my own Candle whip up
any smells and flavors biiis on with
that bag what we do I'm trying to get my
own CBD water to come out I'm just
trying to yeah I'm trying to do a little
bit everything cuz I demand for it man
and you put on also though the first
time we were to your shop you have your
own East Zone dabs - yeah that's yeah
that's that's a part of the flavor line
so like she was strong I gave you the
grape soda that was fine yeah that great
so that's fine actually that's whatever
sanity you guys just grape soda and for
instance con crema is a number one
selling flavor for us right here yeah
like this Italian wedding is like movie
is more of an indica and I remember that
day we ought to get faded because we
have barely got the dad's like I was I
was literally excited over the fact that
I had just gotten that flavor so you
came in at the right day
[ __ ] that [ __ ] up and people like would
hopefully we would some cuffs is here
that's all that's all I'm looking
forward to but ease own your strain it's
gonna be up for award we're going to try
to enter it too for these some of these
upcoming events like because you know
that's what you try to do get some
recognition when it comes to like if you
have something I'm on the exotic side
like I like I like I like I consider the
exotics because it's not your regular
kind of weed like the genetics come from
up north and yeah I hadn't had to kind
of look for it and stuff like that and
then aside from that just looking
forward to a lot of merch like our merch
should be available at chalice we have
three designs coming out as we don't
slump the same as a group so like just
make sure you look out for that and it
will be and check out the website
although all my merchants are merch is
going to be available then on this site
right now so far it says we don't smoke
the same table Big Cartel calm
where can they follow us check uh shake
a Dalek you can follow me on IG Alec
psychedelic that's a sh e i ka de LIC or
on snapchat
Shiki be real TV and yeah that's pretty
much it you can follow me I don't sell
[ __ ] like ease on or have weed or
anything I just [ __ ] rat that's just
my thing
yeah yeah I mean you do you do so you
sell yourself though no but my I don't
sell myself like that your battle people
uh I'm like my I'm going to like song
writing machine instead of battling
people that's my thing that is full
gives down with the pen dog like I like
I like I like more and less like um that
commercial kind of true new trap wave
kind of [ __ ] like I liked I knew that
new [ __ ] at some reason I think like we
we like it like cuffs just keep I don't
know for me I look at it like it helps
us keep like ourselves on our toes like
so like whenever I need to sharpen my
knife when it comes to that boom bap
[ __ ] he kills I like get on his like
I'll be like yo what do you got and then
like whenever like he wants to make
something different or like something
like like you know some trappers or
something that's like not what he would
normally look for like I like tille
he'll look for what I got
how long you known each other five years
yeah five years yeah food you tell
anybody out there who's listening who's
trying to get into them into um
marijuana marijuana or any kind of
endeavor like or just trying to follow
your passion yeah this product of
passion man this that's how I ended up
here like I graduated from college and
marketing right enough communications
the minor marketing so what is it um I
ended IND DUP graduating from college at
Cal State Northridge I got my degree
over there and I didn't know what the
[ __ ] I was going to do after college I
thought I was gonna end up was
undeclared yeah I thought I was yeah I
thought I was gonna end up working at a
[ __ ] of the clothing company I was
wait at that time and sure enough what
is it I got out of college I was out
there didn't know what the [ __ ] to do I
was about to work at Enterprise
automatically qualified for a [ __ ]
like manager position right and during
that week I get a conference Imperial TV
saying would you like a [ __ ]
internship and my taking the internship
landed me my first opportunity with
young and reckless clothing so I was
like you know what I might have
bite the bullet but I can hustle it out
for a year if it doesn't work out so I
left that [ __ ] job that [ __ ]
guaranteed like 80k your enterprise and
I said you know what [ __ ] I'm gonna
go try this out and I just never look
back
hell yeah like I was like [ __ ] it and I
ended I made this [ __ ] was well fools
Arquette you have your own show together
- right yeah we do a Google was on it
yeah yeah we do
that's a that's actually just started we
don't smoke the same podcast on YouTube
make sure you look out for that but get
on the next time man yeah yeah we got a
three on it yeah we do that's gonna be
late we get that we're gonna if you do
come on that if you do come on there
we're gonna have something crazy like
something crazy dog like I might what if
I make me do a rail of Keith dogs oh
hell no we'll bring Rodrigo for that
[ __ ] though yeah for real break that
will be like a full career doll where's
that vacuum nose don't we sit out what
is it I'm gonna try to get a special
blunt made for that day not oh yeah bro
thank you precise me like a [ __ ]
because we beginning something like
crazy blunts we smoked out of guns a
five pound RPG like we have nother
there's the others there's RPG a five
pound RPG blood that was lit by be real
and was a CT teacher resistor yeah
[ __ ] a [ __ ] five pound blood I got
to see HR for throwing that [ __ ] I made
out of gold RPG and like bro like I
think you only got to like two pounds
before like they had a Predacon quarter
everything not even a quarter of it and
that building was packed well it was RPG
like I like the size of a RPG like be
real had it like hold it on his shoulder
and like it goes my bad guy was like
hahaha
I always wish you would have been here
to hear that one I got it replayed on
the show he can [ __ ] listen to the
podcast yeah that's crazy better [ __ ]
RPG joint you guys don't get to finish
it Dan
I didn't have it as a trophy at CHR yeah
the other have it as a trophy a CHR and
that shit's crazy man you instagrams
they could get ahold you Instagram chica
Delic follow me all that you can find
all my new work people be that I mean a
be on lookout for that new Cyprus record
because I did some work on that tomorrow
hell yeah I'm back on tour huh they're
about to they had like four weeks before
Europe to her yeah make sure you get
your tickets [ __ ] Europeans you can
find me and he's on the farm
are we done cheeky yeah glad you're good
you can find me at ease on the firm on
Instagram the SoundCloud is a SoundCloud
calm / the firm or that's ba fi RM come
see as a [ __ ] child support check out
the products you can find out their
flavors by ease own and yeah aside from
that just stay tuned for the collabs and
the new music just to come and make sure
you [ __ ] buy something off the
website we don't support the same job
Dakar Telecom was so food
thank you for Dollar Shave Club for
hooking us up with a sponsor
shout out to add rego and Mexico with
his shine and hopefully that'll work out
Lisa Esparza right here manager are
wheeled and steal her engineer a hole
over here chillin with a jurassic park
shirt
chillin I have that same shirt hell yeah
man how many tattoos do you have
cartoons I don't and I haven't counted
them all off blowing there's probably
like it's probably like a good like more
than a half sleeve because it's just a
collage he just Homer he just started
drawing and painting I mean just ain't
[ __ ] tatting whatever he could go
crazy dog
that was my first tattoo dog oh yeah I
had it two tattoos by somebody [ __ ]
up my original tattoo does I really the
first one usually is it's a [ __ ] up
set if I showed you what this look like
the lion you get like your homie dies to
write your mom's name on it and come at
it look it look like it was um poached
little eye but that a Bob Marley right
there yeah that's what that's the
[ __ ] the portrait I got right there
man there's like Bob Marley slash
[ __ ] Zack de la Rocha
yeah those who say that I myself was
gonna hell yeah Rage Against the Machine
done a rager bro can you still be real
cause it was all full podcasting with
more psychedelic and ease own yeah firm
make sure you [ __ ] we keep in mind we
don't smoke the same up for this photo
time